mother with no underlying conditions
that's what's so frightening when you
hear stories like that
listen it's all frightening thank you
thank you very much
turning now to new protests over the
presence of federal agents in portland
oregon
overnight those agents tear gassed a
group including the mayor of portland
who has accused them of using quote
unconstitutional terror tactics on
american citizens
president trump says federal officers
will soon be deployed in even more
cities
across this country carter evans has
been covering the portland protest
for us
a chaotic scene in portland again
overnight federal agents sent by
president trump guarding a courthouse
unleashed tear gas and rubber bullets on
demonstrators
protesting the officer's continued
presence
some in the crowd launched fireworks
toward the building drawing
this response even portland's democratic
mayor ted wheeler was caught in the
melee
he told the new york times in this video
he was cheergate
before the escalation wheeler had joined
the crowd and directly
addressed the protesters for the first
time in six weeks we are on the front
line
here in portland if we are not
able to get the federal administration
to back off
and leave our city it will happen all
across
the united states jeopardizing our
united states constitution
but there are no signs the feds will
ease up cbs news has learned the
department of homeland security is
looking for more agents to head to
portland for
30 day deployments hours earlier
president trump announced he was sending
federal agents to other american cities
run by democrats
he views as weak on crime when they
abdicate their duty the results are
catastrophic
more than 200 federal agents have been
sent to kansas city
a similar number are now heading to
chicago which has seen a 48 percent rise
in the murder rate over the last year
and 35 agents are deploying to
albuquerque
the president is trying to divert
attention from his
failed leadership on covet 19.
he has failed tom ridge former secretary
of homeland security
and a republican says the president is
playing politics
and violating the mission of the
department which was formed in the
aftermath of 9 11. used to help combat
terrorism and defend this country from
terrorism and
was not designed to be the president's
or any federal agency wasn't designed to
be the president's
personal militia now chicago's mayor
lightfoot had been
vehemently opposed to having those
federal officers in her
city but after a phone call with
president trump yesterday she now
appears to have changed her mind
she will accept those officers and says
they will be deployed
for investing